this is a production of cornell
university
such an intimate setting for all of this
as well i
most of my settings i talk a lot with
growers so they can all fit right here
in front of me they don't normally sit
way in the back
because i generally bring
things that people like to eat
now in deference to all the signs in
here these are visual aids today
and
later in the afternoon when or during
the poster session they'll be out and
you'll get a chance to taste some of
these visual aids and see see what i'm
talking about when it comes to
breeding and berry
so i work in berry crops small fruits
really is what we call it
raspberry black raspberry which is
native to this region strawberry
blackberries these are things people eat
every day people are very familiar with
them and of course none of them are
berries if you remember your
freshman biology class plant biology
none of these are in actual berries as
fruits but
horticulturally and
commercially of course are considered
berries
it's a very complex group of plants
they are all in the rosaceas family and
the ploidy levels are all over the place
so from the breeding standpoint it
provides us
an opportunity
to experiment with many different
systems of breeding so if raspberries
are the simplest being a diploid plant
which is very nice
it's the crop we've also done most of
our genomic work on because the genome
is fairly simple and fairly small
strawberry is the most
is very complex it's an interspecific
auto allo octoploid
two wild species that were accidentally
introduced at some point in the 1700s
so most of the genome work there has
been done on a related diploid species
that is not used in breeding and then
the blackberries all over the place in
the wild you see 2n equals 2x but you
see odd ploidies
boysenberry is a 7x it's a very
common berry that people have heard of
people are like how does it produce
fruit well it does because there's
apomixis pseudogammy all sorts of
strange things in blackberry so the
genome work in these and some of the
other
genera are a little
behind because they are so complex
so my program is research and extension
extension is very applied
aspect of my research my research is
also very applied towards the grower
towards the actual consumer
we have collaborators all the way from
home gardeners i have an 85 year old
woman in washington who helps me test
some of my varieties she's very happy to
tell her neighbors she's the first one
to ever test
a new variety in the state of washington
and she sends me nice letters about how
it grows in her backyard
and then we have multinational
corporations as well that work with us
and
we'll plant
varieties on a large scale for
commercial markets for shipping all over
the uh in this case in europe and in
north america
retail nurseries commercial nurseries
really in the in the berry world we
we work with all of these people because
there are different audiences
almost everybody likes berries at least
one or one of them
and people like to eat them every day
there's growing consumption in the us
they're considered to be very good for
you so all of these things drive
consumption and drive interest in
berries
we have domestic
direct domestic collaboration here in
the state of new york the new york state
berry growers association has an
agreement with cornell they test my new
material pre-commercialization so that
growers can see it ahead of time and get
a look
at these varieties and give me feedback
on them and then we have international
collaborators as well in canada in the
european union mexico
japan has recently signed on for one of
our varieties so we see interest in
berries growing all over the world
our extension is much on the variety
trials not only my own program but from
other programs around the country and
around the world and also technology new
technologies that make berry
growing much more feasible for new york
you see these high tunnels
we've been picking high berries in that
high tunnel since mid-june
this tray was picked yesterday we'll
still be picking for another couple of
weeks it provides a crop in the in new
york that you can pick for months at a
time it provides them the opportunity to
get into markets for a very long time as
well
new york growers are very close to their
consumers
they often are marketing their fruit
within a day or two of when it's picked
so consumers are much more aware of the
quality standards and this type of
technology really increases the quality
we hold grower trials or field days
where growers actually come to the farms
in geneva we lay out the fruit they get
to taste it they talk to me directly
they get to see
exactly how to grow it and what's
available
and this really brings a lot of
excitement to um
to the industry it's really it's for me
it's very satisfying to
to interact with the growers and have
them
tell me you know my variety is doing
well that's what i like to hear
sometimes they tell me they don't like
my varieties that's good to hear too
although not as fun to hear
sometimes the extension work is not as
simple as it seems
this happened
two days three days after we got it set
up we had the eye of a hurricane pass
over the top
kind of turned it into a mangled mess
that was a monday morning picture it was
a good week
so the science behind it so the breeding
is fairly traditional in in berries
recurrent selection
we're looking at each generation picking
out the best ones from each generation
recombinating recombin recombining those
to try and improve the next generation
it's fairly straightforward
but easier said than done
as most genetic theory since everything
goes back to the midparent
which we're trying to get everything
that's better than the parents and
that's a very difficult thing to do
sometimes
they are generally out crossing
they're all self-pollinated crops
but they all suffer from inbreeding
depression
so
you need outcrossing you need genetic
diversity in order to make improvement
which then gives you things that you
don't necessarily expect
black raspberry is a little bit on the
outlier because it
my theory is that it had a genetic
bottleneck during the ice ages
it is localized in the northeastern
united states and southeastern canada
and it's very very inbred as a species
so there's not a whole lot of diversity
and they do we do mix up the species
especially in rubus
you can cross red raspberry black
raspberry you can cross raspberry with
blackberry if deployed is right
and there are some other wild species
that are used for some interesting
trades
molecular techniques we started
certainly with genetic mapping there was
no map when i started here at cornell
we we published maps um
with disease resistance on them for
phytophthora especially we've moved into
some rna-seq work looking at disease
resistance as well phytophthora work
looking at the differences between
resistant and and
susceptible phenotypes so in raspberry
on the plus side to work with they're
clonal so when you have a plant you can
reproduce that same exact genetic plant
as many times as you want and so it
makes it very nice as a model for for
working in in this type of
field
that then branched into genome
sequencing there was no genome for
raspberry there was no genome for
any small fruit at that time
that genome then is is finished but not
published yet and uh we're working on
getting that paper out so we'll have
more tools as we move forward
the potential for marker assisted
selection certainly we are looking for
ways to speed things up putting things
out in the field watching them grow for
two or three years is a very slow way to
do it especially when you have new york
where you get a 20-minute hail storm
come across your field in july which
happened this year all the fruit for
about three weeks was damaged
there's not a whole lot of evaluation
you can do when that happens
so we want to be able to reduce that
number of plants that are in the field
make sure the ones that we are observing
actually have the treats that we're
interested
in
so one of my students came up with this
hydroponic system phytophthora and
raspberry is a root disease
it's very hard to observe the roots in a
system like that
so we came up with this hydroponic
system you can see on the left
your left
plants really like growing in the system
when you introduce the phytophthora the
susceptible ones die and we can look at
the difference in
expression of genes
from these same plants before they are
infected and after the infected
then we can also look at
clonally
individual varieties that have
resistance and ones that don't the
resistance in the species has been very
very durable there's a variety that's
known for it been released it was
released in 1908
it's a very durable resistance and we're
very interested in figuring out how that
works
so the genetic mapping showed there were
two genes involved two major gene
covering somewhere between
50
50 55 percent of the genetic variation
between these two traits and no matter
how we measured it we measured it just
on a one to five scale we measured the
stem lesions we measured how much of the
petioles got lesions we measured just
the root score just how dead were the
roots anywhere from a little bit of life
to
no effect whatsoever no matter how we
measured it those two spots in the
genome popped up again and again in the
mapping so we're pretty confident that
there's some serious
genes involved two major genes involved
of course there's
when you're looking at disease
resistance and you're looking at root
traits there's certainly a lot of other
things that go and go along with that
some of the work we've done so the rna
seq work
we took those two when we we compared
the rna expression before infection
after infection in a resistant variety
and a susceptible variety
we've narrowed it down to
a few dozen genes involved that were
very highly up regulated during the
process there were some others that were
very highly down regulated and were
wading through all of that data it seems
that data overload is what we have at
this point trying to figure out
our next target to look at
in black raspberry we have a prop a
multi multi-state program right now
working at black raspberry with a very
very minor crop
but one people are very interested in
because antioxidant levels are off
through the roof on black raspberry it's
high in fiber and vitamin b and vitamin
c and all these good things and it
tastes good too which is even better you
know most of these new berries the new
superfruits you know the kai berry and
these they don't really taste very good
you know aronia you have to mix them
with something that tastes good to take
them and so to have a super fruit that
actually tastes good
would be a boon i think for the industry
there's some very interesting work done
at ohio state as well on black
raspberries direct freeze-dried powders
on pre-cancerous lesions in the mouth
and oral cavity
reversing some of these lesions
lesions in the esophagus which is
esophageal cancer is one of the worst
cancers for fatality for mortality
taking powders of direct powders of
black raspberries reversing some of
these lesions so people are very
interested in this crop but it's a very
difficult crop to produce in any volume
and so this we're looking at
uh we're looking at the genetics of it
in multiple locations we're also looking
at consumer preferences and chemical
analysis of the fruit to see what
how we can make improvements in this
crop it really has
barely been scratched as far as breeding
i did a study a few years ago all the
commercial varieties the farthest one
away from a wild
parent was two generations
some of the varieties were actually
plants people found in ditches
and they named them and that's
considered a commercial variety that's
how new this crop is to breeding so we
think we can make some really
great progress in a crop like this
and that's where kind of the art comes
into this since we don't have a lot of
information on a lot of these things we
have anecdotal evidence we have
direct
interaction with growers and we use this
information to
to try to figure out what the consumer
wants to try and figure out what the
grower wants and try to merge those two
things in new varieties
you talk to people they always say they
want flavor
the flavor is kind of a tough thing in
in berries and in fruit crops in general
so
what is flavor so i assume everybody
here has had an apple at some point in
their life
and you know what an apple tastes like
right
so which one's an apple
this tastes like an apple right
granny smith of course this tastes like
an apple too
it's an empire this one tastes like an
apple it's a gala but they don't taste
like each other
so which one's the apple
well they all are and they not none of
them are there is no apple flavor
there's
all different flavors that all remind
you of what
everybody has in their mind what an
apple should be
but they have the luxury of naming them
and people can say well this one i like
granny smith apples i like gala
strawberries don't have that advantage
there are no named varieties in the
supermarket in this country the european
market is moving to having all the
varieties on the containers and
retailers here well producers here
are not for it
companies like driscoll's nature ripe
they worked very hard to get their names
on those
on those uh containers and they don't
really want to
sorry i've been pushing buttons haven't
i
so we work with this with with so what
what does the producer want well this
producer wants big berries big berries
pick easy they fill containers quickly
the biggest cost in berry production is
labor it's all hand-picked
they want shelf life they want to be
able to ship that sucker from california
in four days to new york city and it
looks good still
if it tastes good oh that's that's good
but it is not the top priority
my wife was talking about this last
night with my wife she's like you know
when you need strawberries for the
fruit salad you can buy any strawberries
at the supermarket you know it doesn't
matter you're mixing them they're going
to buy them people do buy strawberries
we do see though in new york
in strawberry season the driscoll sales
go down
because people do want good strawberries
and they will go out and find local
strawberries
and they will stop buying them from the
supermarket when they can
so there's a lot of room a lot of
potential for innovation new categories
new colors flavor shapes these things
are all available that are not been
marketed in the supermarket right now
the category for raspberries is big and
red and the category for strawberries
it's big and red
and that's pretty much where we're at
and there's so much more in the berry
world that's available
the industry can move very very quickly
as well but it can also stand still
so when you look in a catalog this is
from norse farms one of our biggest
nurseries in this region they grow
a lot of different varieties they sell
them all over the country just in
raspberry strawberries and blackberries
they have 64 varieties available because
that's a lot of information for growers
to take in it's an astounding amount of
information for a consumer to take in
they're from all over the world
different states different countries
seven of the strawberry varieties were
more than 20 years old
one of the raspberry varieties the one i
was telling you about released in 1908
still sold commercially
so on the one hand we have
people willing to try new things and on
the other hand we have people who will
never try new things
they've been growing this variety for 42
years
it works for them they're making money
i'm not going to argue with that
but there's a lot of opportunity
so of course this is what we'd like to
see even for me i'm still like to have a
nice commercially successful variety we
want one with big red berries people
like big red berries
they taste good it's even better if we
can get a good tasting big red berry
into the new york market for local
growers that's a very good thing
this is crimson giant one of our our
raspberry releases this is an example of
what can happen at lightning speed so i
was approached in 2007 by a company in
spain who wanted to get into berry
production they'd gotten out of
asparagus because the peruvians had
driven them out of the market and they
were down to one product stone fruit
peaches
and they needed to diversify
so that was 2007 and 2014 they have
about thirteen hundred acres of berries
all of it under undercover so there's
thirteen hundred acres of tunnels
stretching as far as you can see it's a
pretty impressive thing so in seven
years they've gone from nothing no sales
at all to that level
this variety we sent that 25 plants to
them in 2008 to test
by 2009 they said they wanted to go to
commercial
in 2010 they ordered 400 thousand plants
to plant a hundred acres
which would produce somewhere between a
million and a million and a half pounds
of raspberries or three to three to
three to a half million units
unit of raspberry the little
half pint and they were going to market
those
over a four month period
things would go really really fast
by 2014 they decided they didn't like
the variety anymore and they're done
with it they move on to a new variety
because they can plant the variety in
april by october they have fruit by the
next april they don't like it they
change varieties or on to the next one
things can happen really really fast in
the in the berry world
consumers change their preferences of
course in europe too there's there's
variety name on every container so they
get very direct feedback from the
consumer saying i like this variety i
don't like this variety and they can
actually tell them which variety it is
and that's
it's a double-edged sword you know if
you're
that's the only variety you have
you're kind of stuck
but if you have the ability to change
varieties very quickly you can maybe
address those consumer concerns or if
you have a variety that no one else has
that they really like your sales can go
through the roof
this company sells tremendous amount of
fruit to norway in the winter time and
they have one variety that norwegians
really like
when that variety hits the market sales
double
overnight because the people are looking
for it they're waiting for it
that's the kind of thing that can happen
if the marketing and the production
all goes the way you want it
a new one we're coming along again big
red berries we were still growers
even new york growers like big red
berries too but there's a lot of things
besides big red berries so we have a
purple raspberry
our strawberry that we put out a couple
of years ago named walker it's being
marketed as a purple wonder by burpee
you see their
their page
they're selling it for 10.95
per plant
so they don't have to sell very many
um to give you an idea a commercial
nursery sells plants by the thousand and
a thousand bare root plants costs about
110 dollars
so for the same price you can get 10 of
these
or you can get a thousand commercial
ones
so
and people are buying they can't they
can't produce enough plants people love
them because
home gardeners it's the biggest biggest
uh
hobby in the united states is home
gardening
and people love new stuff people love
stuff they can't get in the supermarket
we have some new raspberry varieties
becoming very popular local markets this
nice apricot color you see here
it helps it tastes great but it also
catches the eye
a dark berry
so that's not red in the in the
supermarket that's over ripe
but on a farmer's market stand
it really stands out people really like
to taste it
that's the thing in new york growers a
lot of them are
directly interacting with their
consumers people are tasting the product
before they get to the car sometimes
sometimes before they actually get to
the counter to sell it or to buy it and
so
if it doesn't taste good for new york
growers it's a big deal you know berries
is the third leading fruit crop in new
york and people don't really think of it
much but
every place you have a
concentration of people in new york you
have a concentration of berry growers
around that area around rochester around
ithaca around buffalo around albany
because people want fresh berries and
they want local berries
we have some nice bright yellow lemon
yellow type berries
they really stand out they taste good
they taste like
they taste like raspberries
we certainly want ones that taste really
good
purple ones too
so when you cross a red raspberry in a
black raspberry you get purple
raspberries
that's a category that doesn't exist in
the supermarket so
as we get things that are different
if you're working with the right
companies we can suddenly get a new
category get new shelf space and people
can look for new things
and it's really i mean from my point of
view it's very exciting we make some of
these crosses we don't know exactly what
the fruit is going to look like
and it can be a lot of fun
to try
see what we can get of course the
mythical blue raspberry flavor
thankfully
there are no such things raspberries
that color uh
there's there's been pictures going
around the internet every so often
claiming these are gmo raspberries
there's gmo strawberries are that same
color
they don't exist
so it's all it's all urban legend they
could i guess
genetic transformation strawberries and
raspberries is
simple
well characterized well worked out
and not of any interest to the consumer
at this time so
most of the traits that have been done
disease resistance roundup ready
growers would like it consumers have
not wanted it the industry has been
terrified of it because of negative
connotations their markets often
overseas
especially the frozen and they don't
want anything to do with it
so there's a bright future i think in
berry sorry for the pun
but uh
you know in 2002 raspberry production
fresh raspberries the only place they
took stats was in california
it was around 40 million
10 years before that it was around 25
million that was kind of growth by 2009
in california alone it hit 350 million
just for raspberries
it could grow really really fast things
really happen it's backed off a little
bit now as labor problems in in
california and land use issues
productions moved down to mexico
same companies same varieties free trade
trucks come right in
so a lot of the production has moved to
mexico but there's still over 250
million dollars in fresh raspberries
produced in california each year
strawberries from year to year are right
there with apples as far as production
in in the us you know third leading
fruit crop in the u.s behind citrus and
grapes
third lady fruit crop in new york behind
apples and grapes
people like strawberries they eat them
all the time
about two and a half billion dollars in
strawberries were produced in the u.s
last year and we import more from mexico
and canada
the local food movement too really is
driving some of this demand for new
varieties they want choices they want
quality
anybody can go to the supermarket and
get big red berries
and we can get big red berries every day
of the year
but when you want something special you
want something different
you go to the farmer's market you go to
the local market and there's a lot of a
lot of choices and a lot of things
available now that weren't available
even five years ago so
with that i'll close i will have the
berries out they'll become food aids
after no longer visual aids during the
during the poster session you can
take a taste
well earliness is a tricky
thing
because there's multiple seasons
so earliness in the spring is
we've pretty much reached the limit of
where we can get on earliness in
raspberry any earlier and the flowers
get continually get killed so until we
go into completely into protective
culture for breeding as well it's very
difficult to get earlier where we're
moving earlier is in the fall crop in
the in the varieties that produce fruit
on their first year's growth
we've moved into late late july early
august so we can have fruit from that
time until november
if we could move that another couple
weeks earlier
we could even you know we can expand
that season and that's the season that's
the type of plants being grown in mexico
in california
you plant a plant and
four months later it's flowering and
producing fruit and so if you can move
that forward you can expand your season
there
there is very much so there's been quite
a bit of work on
chemical composition certainly it
berries and
correlation to what flavor is
it often comes down to the same two
things sugar and acid in the ratio
between the two
but yet there are always those varieties
that everybody recognizes as being
superior
and they don't seem to have a different
sugar acid ratio
from most of the other varieties so
there's a lot of we a proposal that
unfortunately was not funded had a big
aspect of that in it
you know when you work with specialty
crops sometimes the resources involved
to do that is are are limited but
there's a lot of interest in that and
what flavor is
and the combination of flavor and
firmness
everybody's had a strawberry probably
they've bitten into and it kind of
crunched
so we there is no limit to how firm you
can make a strawberry you can make it so
it will not ripen
so that it will stay firm you can ship
it all the way around the world but
nobody wants to eat it so where's that
balance of how firm is too firm and
where does the flavor come from
in that combination because our
varieties are so firm you don't want to
eat it but their sugar levels are off
off the chart so if we could back off on
the firmness the flavor would probably
be outstanding
but so there is a lot of interest but
not a lot of work unfortunately
okay thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu